create a list of steps in order that
will solve the following equation and it
gives the equation here and then they
have a bunch of steps that they want us
to put in order so let's just work it
out on this scratch pad you might be
able to work these out in your head
eventually but i'll do it on this
scratch pad first so first i'm just
going to solve this the way that i might
try to solve it so let's say we have 5x
minus 11 is equal to 42
and as we've seen before whenever i like
to solve something i like to isolate the
variable that i'm trying to solve for so
i want to isolate this 5x on one side
and then eventually i'm going to try to
get that into being an x
so the best way to get to isolated is to
get rid of this minus 11. well the best
way to get this minus get rid of that
minus 11 on the left hand side is to add
11 to the left hand side but i can't
just do it only to the left hand side
then these two things won't be equal
anymore in order for them to both be
equal i have to do the same thing to
both sides
and then i would be left with well
negative 11 plus 11 is going to be zero
i'm going to be left with 5x
is equal to 53.
so what was the first step that i just
did
well i added 11 to both sides
so this is going to be
my first step
now what what do i do to solve this
well once again i want this to be in the
form of x equals something that i know
what x is well what's the best way to
just have an x here on the left hand
side
well i could divide 5x by 5. that would
give me x but once again if i want these
two things to be equal to each other i
have to do the same thing to both sides
so i have to divide 53 by 5 as well
and then i'll be left with
i'll be left with
x is equal to 53
over 5 and i am done i have solved for
the x that satisfies this equation so
what's the next thing that i did well i
divided both sides by five so this right
over here step two i added 11 to both
sides then divide both sides by five so
let's fill that in
so i'm going to add 11 to both sides
adding 11 to both sides then i'm just
left with 5x is equal to 53
and then i divide both sides by 5.
got it right